Hollywood is always looking for that
next big thing the next big popular show
and a lot of people in Hollywood think
they know what it's going to be
fall out
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so if you are the sort of person that
loves a good game then you will know the
Fallout series it's a game that's been
very popular that I have and never
played because I don't really get into
gaming I stopped gaming when I was about
13.
but for the people that do love it they
say that this is actually a really
exciting project that Amazon have
currently got themselves and that actual
filming recently wrapped so we're going
to be getting the Fallout series sooner
rather than later by the end of this
year or by the start of maybe 2024 but
why am I talking about it well if you
are regular sidetracking earlier then I
do speak to a few people within the
Hollywood industry and they are saying
that the big hype at the moment is this
show now this year the last of us has
been kind of that show that got
everybody talking got everybody excited
where'd you be without me huh
by now Wyoming oh yeah walked into that
one and Amazon really think the Fallout
will have a similar impact so early test
footage has apparently been going around
the industry and I actually spoke to a
couple of people that have seen some of
that early test footage and apparently
everybody that has seen it agrees that
this is going to be a really really good
show it's going to be very dark very
gritty it's going to be incredibly
violent set in a post-apocalyptic World
following a massive nuclear conflict
[Applause]
hold on cities are laid to ruin in the
21st century war was still waged over
the resources that could be acquired
Humanity was almost completely wiped out
for these resources China would invade
Alaska the US would Annex Canada and the
European Commonwealth would dissolve
into quarreling bickering nation states
and the few pockets of people left
in 2077 the storm of world war had come
again
in two brief hours most of the planet
was reduced to Cinders have incredibly
difficult and violent lives
a few were able to reach the relative
safety of the large underground vaults
your family was part of that group that
entered Vault 13. now the main actors
we're going to get to see in this is
while Ella Pernell a British actress
which means she'll be good but she we
actually saw in um Maleficent and a few
other things and Walton Goggins an actor
that I absolutely adore as soon as I saw
him in Justified a few years ago he's
also in the Predators movie and he plays
his like white supremacist guy who's got
oh he's just Fantastic look at you sue
a necktie looking good
looking like a law man
hmm
a brilliant actor who I can't wait to
see in this role he actually plays a
ghoul a human being that's had so much
radiation Etc that he's been turned into
something else a brilliant character
actor that I'm sure will bring his a
game to this project so who are the
actual creators behind the show and
should we be getting excited about who's
actually writing it well Christopher
Nolan I don't know if you know this has
a brother Jonathan Nolan they actually
collaborated on lots of Christopher
Nolan's early projects Jonathan Roland
actually wrote the short story that
Christopher Nolan then turned into the
movie Memento they worked on a couple of
The Dark Knight movies together I'm
Batman they did the screen pay for um
Interstellar together and the early
Christopher Nola movie The Prestige more
recently Jonathan Nolan has been working
with Lisa Joy they actually did the
Westworld series together now they're
moving on and working with Amazon to
create this new series and I have to
admit the pedigree of the creators on
this one are excellent I know I know
Westworld was not always the best but
the first series was brilliant and
Jonathan Nolan and Lisa Joy do really
seem to know what they're doing when
making this type of show now turning
games into television series and movies
has always been something the Studios
have tried to do as soon as they get
anything within any genre that's popular
Hollywood will try to make it into a
film
and they've not always been particularly
successful
but Hollywood seems to have figured out
how to do it they seem to have stopped
making these things for children for one
and started making them for adults
always a good idea
but even when they do it for kids they
seem to have figured out how to do it
the Mario Brothers movie that's coming
out I'm pretty sure it's going to be
much much better than the original with
Bob Hoskins
we've seen things like the Sonic the
Hedgehog movies recently that are
actually quite good and there's been a
couple of streaming series that were
based Loosely or entirely on games that
have actually managed to be again pretty
good
Uncharted the movie recently with Tom
Holland Etc wasn't great but it was okay
but for me the secret for this one is to
do exactly what Amazon are doing don't
make a movie where you have to tell a
lot of story very very quickly
do a stream in series where you get the
8-10 hours that you need to tell the
story properly that you get a flow to
the series that you need and you don't
have to rush anything or worse for a lot
of fans of the game cut big bits of the
story out I'm really looking forward to
seeing what Amazon are gonna do with
this now we may get Halo which I have to
admit I did enjoy
what was a little boring in places and
really Dragged In places I mean it
really it's really hard to actually
watch in places where they dragged or we
can get something like the last of us
which is a really good honest telling of
the story in a really interesting new
way I'm hoping for the latter because
you don't have to have played the game
to enjoy The Last of Us it was just a
really good story told really really
well I am told by people that have
played Fallout that there's a big story
there to tell as well
and hopefully we're going to get to see
that told really really well by creators
that have had a pretty good history of
doing a good job
but either way everybody so far that's
seen it is saying that Fallout is going
to be the big exciting new project for
2024. we're going to get into the
comments tell me what you think have you
ever played Fallout has it got a
storyline that you are excited to see in
a new streaming service series format or
are you actually already getting a bit
bored of big studios like this telling
gaming stories come up with something
new do something original I'd love for
you to get into the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our newest
videos also you can check out the
description there's loads of related
Side Track stuff including Facebook link
uh Discord server where people go and
have a nice chat and things like our
Twitter account
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month you can get to
see them first and without the adverts
it also really helps the channel
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
[Music]